the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video
in this video i will show you what i
believe is the number one scene that
foreshadowed exactly how game of thrones
would end
now as you all know game of thrones had
one of the most controversial endings in
television history
as you all know there were a lot of
different things that happened during
the final season that left millions of
fans feeling either unsatisfied or in
many cases very angry
what i will be focusing on in this video
is what happened during dany's final
moments in the show
i think it's safe to say that a lot of
us did feel blindsided by how daenerys
targaryen story ended
now although there may be several scenes
that did foreshadow what would happen to
this character
i believe there is one scene that stands
above the rest
not only did it foreshadow how daenerys
would react during the battle for king's
landing but it also foreshadowed her
death
now what's interesting is dany could
have avoided her own demise if only she
had some of her guards with her while
she was standing in the throne room of
the red keep
daenerys should have had her security
with her everywhere she went
however just because she left herself
exposed doesn't mean you have to
let me give you an example every single
one of you who are watching and
listening to this video right now
are on the internet unfortunately
whenever you're on the internet your
valuable information could be under
attack
but the good thing is you can fix that
right now before i go any
further i want to thank nordvpn for not
only sponsoring this video but also
standing in as my own
virtual kingsguard that's right my
friends whenever i'm on the internet
they make sure i'm safe by watching my
back
now for those of you who don't know
nordvpn is an award-winning
virtual private network that helps keep
your identity
data and information safe while you are
browsing online
the service is very easy to use they
have their own app that you can use on
your phone
as well as a chrome browser extension
for those of you who may be using a
desktop or laptop
all your information could be safe and
secure and only a few clicks
it really is a great service to have if
you are on the internet as much as i am
especially if you're always on a wi-fi
connection a lot of them are not even
secured
and that leaves you exposed if you do
most of your banking or shopping online
like most of us do these days our
information and data is extremely
vulnerable
even our passwords just because this
information is saved on our devices
does not mean it is safe another thing
that is really great about nordvpn is
you can use it on up to six different
devices
and all six of those devices would be
secured at the same time
now just in case you would need any
extra help they also offer
24 7 customer support there is also a 30
day money back guarantee
so if there is any reason you don't want
their service you could get a refund
as long as it's within those 30 days now
before we move on there is one other
awesome feature i must mention
some of you might not know this but
nordvpn does more than just offer you
online security
their service also allows you to access
different things that may not be
available in your country
like websites or movies and television
shows on netflix
this is one of the things that i love
most about them now you see
netflix offers different movies shows
and documentaries based on the country
you live in
however with nordvpn you can unlock all
the hidden entertainment
that you would not have access to
otherwise if you sign up right now
nordvpn is offering a two-year plan with
an amazing discount
as well as a bonus gift for my
subscribers all you have to do is go to
nordvpn.com
forward slash talking thrones i would
highly recommend that you check it out
once again i want to thank nordvpn for
sponsoring the video
now let me show you what i believe is
the number one scene that foreshadows
how game of thrones would end
although there were many different
scenes that are considered as
foreshadowing
there was actually one scene that showed
us exactly what would happen during some
of the biggest moments
in the final episodes of the show now
this scene may have gave us an early
glimpse into what would happen to dany
in the end
but it still doesn't fix how it was
handled in the final season
as you all know there were actually a
lot of scenes that hinted at the
direction danny was setting in
but it still felt like it was forced at
the end because of how fast she
drastically changed
they even shoved in a lot of those
scenes at the very end right before
daenerys attacked king's landing
if you remember at the very beginning of
season 8 episode 5 the bells
they showed us a preview that had all
these different lines of dialogue that
they were using as signs of dany's
inevitable madness
let me show you just in case you don't
remember he has the better playing to
the throne every time a targaryen is
born the gods flip a coin
king gave his enemies the justice he
thought they deserved children and not
their fathers be a dragon you have a
gentle heart targaryen
alone in the world it's a terrible thing
you don't awake the dragon indeed
that was shown right before the bell's
episode officially begun
this was hbo's way of showing us all the
different scenes that was setting up
what daenerys would ultimately do
in this episode when her and drogon laid
waste to the city of king's landing
those were definitely some memorable
moments that could be seen as some
foreshadowing for dany's downfall
however i think they left out the number
one scene that showed us exactly what
would happen
the biggest clue was given to us all the
way back in the last episode of the
second season
when daenerys entered the house of the
undying in this scene
dany gets a glimpse of her own fate this
scene alone led to many fans making
their own theories about what the scene
could mean
i even made some myself well now i think
we know exactly what the scene
represented
we see dany as she enters the great hall
of the red key
as she walks into the throne room we can
also see there is snow falling all over
the ground
as well as the iron throne now there are
a lot of fans who still think this is
ash but it was actually snow
this is confirmed if you listen to the
behind the scenes commentary from the
episode
listen for yourself but this was um the
snow was incredible
yeah our effects guys in belfast were
wonderful and these are
i think that's probably a combination of
snow candles this is all
on the onset snow i don't think we're
doing any cgi stuff here one of the main
reasons fans thought this was ash is
because it's obvious the red keep has
been under attack from above
if you look at the roof you can see
there is damage from what looks like a
fire
now since the fire only seems to have
damaged the ceiling
it seems fairly obvious this must have
been done by a dragon
which we all now know that's exactly
what happened
now i believe there is more than one
reason why snow was falling on the iron
throne
the first reason is rather simple it was
indicating this would not happen until
much later
when winter fell the other reason is
more symbolic
the snow falling on the iron throne
symbolized who was actually the rightful
heir
jon snow it was letting us know jon snow
is next in line before daenerys
this scene also lets us know daenerys
would never sit on the iron throne
either
it was right there within reach but she
would never be able to hold on to it for
long
as a matter of fact it would be the snow
as in jon snow
who would stop her from doing so now
what is really interesting is we saw the
same thing in bran stark's vision as
well
this was during the second episode of
the fourth season when bran was out
beyond the wall with mira jojen and
hodor
this would actually be the first time
bran would see visions through a
weirwood
it also confirmed that bran stark was
getting glimpses of the future
during these visions not only does bran
see the destruction of the iron throne
as it's being covered in snow but he
also sees what led to that happening
in the same visions he sees drogon
flying over king's landing
you can see the shadow of the dragon's
wings over the buildings
and we don't see this happen again until
daenerys and drogon
are attacking king's landing now what
happens next while dany is in the house
of the undying is very interesting as
well
right after she walks away from the iron
throne she suddenly walks out beyond the
wall
where she is reunited with call drogo
and their unborn child
during this scene danny even says maybe
i am dead
and i just don't know it yet
well daenerys was right there is a
reason why this was shown directly after
daenerys stands before the iron throne
that's because it would be the exact
moment jon snow would end her life
in the second season of game of thrones
they showed us exactly where dany's
story would end
now they obviously mishandled the
execution but her fate was already
sealed long before she arrived in
westeros
if you ask me this is the number one
scene that foreshadows how her story
ends
let me know what you think down below do
you agree with this
or do you think there is another scene
that foreshadows the ending
better than this one as always i want to
thank everyone for watching the video
i also want to thank nordvpn once again
for sponsoring the video
i hope all of you have a great day i
will see you soon
[Music]
bye
[Music]
so
you